hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and as of a couple hours ago
Ubisoft had just recently put on their
YouTube channel a trailer for the new
game-mode that was being teased last
week called tribute so I'm going to talk
about what I saw from the trailer and
we're gonna discuss some of the things
afterwards so let's get right into this
so first up judging from the trailer
tribute is gonna be a four view 4
game-mode where your team has to grab
totems scattered throughout the map and
place them at your team shrine or base
you win by getting all three totems at
your shrine now when you put a totem on
your shrine depending on the specific
totem you grabbed it will give your team
a specific buff for example one one of
these blessings will give you your team
a damage boost speed boost when carrying
a totem and faster pickup with taking
the totem from an enemy teams base the
next one will give you a small
regeneration shield and slows down the
enemies trying to take the totem from
your base and the last buff or blessing
is going to give you and show you the
location of opponents on your map I
believe this was a character buff from I
believe this is a feat from another
character and might be Valkyrie and
might be wrong on that one but either
way it's gonna work if that is correct
it is going to work entirely like that
now when you place a totem in your
shrine you're gonna have to defend it
until time runs out because the enemy
team can steal it and take it back to
their base once your team captures it
once the totem has been captured your
team will receive buffs and as I
previously listed depending on which one
you got you will receive that buff the
game modes gonna be like capture the
flag but with a slightly different twist
to it
I personally am very excited for this
mode I don't know if you guys are too
foreigner really hasn't had a new game
mode since launch so I'm very glad they
are doing this type of thing my only
issue with this is that this mode is
gonna be having run is gonna be running
rampant with tons of Shinobi's shinobi
being the character with the fastest
speed in the game he can easily outrun
any opponent as soon as he grabs that
totem especially with the speed boost
you get from the one from the first
offering I mentioned he's just gonna be
a absolute must-have on the team
practically with quad speed so he's
gonna be out running people across the
map it's gonna be crazy it's gonna be
hell either way that's all I've got on
this thing
let me guys know what you guys think
from the trailer I'm personally like I
said I'm very excited for this this is
gonna be talked about a probably a bit
more in-depth on Thursday seeing as the
dev stream is tomorrow so do keep do
keep that in mind and do prepared for
tomorrow I will keep you all to date on
what's going on on Thursday as well as
the other stuff that they mentioned
maybe some more patch notes we'll have
to see as a for release date
I have no exact clue that I was not told
anything but there is a new four before
game mode coming out in season four so
according to you know judging by the
road map that they released at the
beginning of season three so who knows
maybe it's that one I'm really impressed
us game mode seems really great in this
and this game especially needs a fresh
new mode for the players to play so
hopefully it's not going to be that but
either way we'll figure that out on
Thursday anyway guys it's gonna be the
end of the video like the video if you
did enjoy most recent videos popping up
on screen I did a little montage I
decided to do something new this week
that's why I didn't really upload the
past week so if you guys do want to
check that out give some feedback I
would really really appreciate that I
spend a lot of time on that and I
thought even if you guys stay for a
little bit I just thought that you guys
would maybe hopefully enjoy that video
either way once again subscribe if
you're new like the V if you did enjoyed
the newest video on-screen I'll see you
all guys tomorrow and peace out